a new poll finds that 42% of Americans
are not sure who to believe ahead of
this morning's testimony by judge Brett
Kavanaugh and his accuser Christine
Blasi Ford now that is in stark contrast
in 1991 when a Wall Street Journal NBC
News poll found a majority believes
Supreme Court nominee Clarence Thomas
over his accuser Anita Hill CBS News
contributor Jody canter is an
investigative reporter for The New York
Times she co-wrote the very first story
on the Harvey Weinstein's sexual assault
allegations
The Times won a Pulitzer Prize for its
reporting on that story and Jody joins
us at the table what a moment for us all
to be here it's such a drama-filled day
Jody and I think that when you're
sitting and looking at the testimony
what are you looking for today well
remember that we don't even know what
dr. Ford looks like there are very few
pictures of her on the internet but
she's wearing sunglasses and so this
woman who really deliberated over
whether she wanted to tell the story at
all who's a very private comes off as a
very serious person is going to be
walking in front of the American public
and essentially sharing one of her worst
memories with the entire nation for for
judgment for judgment by everybody in
for judgment by this group of senators
if she's already said she's terrified
about coming forward a team but also her
she has one job which is just to relate
the memory of what happened and I think
we're gonna see her stick to that very
very closely you have been in the
business of very carefully talking to
people who have made allegations and
doing what you're supposed to do which
is press them and make sure they're
right and be very skeptical about them
and you must have had an experience
where or let me ask you this way in
public senators this is going to be
happening how does one walk the line
from doing the being skeptical and not
also suggesting that you don't believe
that this can happen that this happens
to women and that broader point well
remember that when we look at dr. Ford's
allegations they have become the her
memories are very clear she always had
some corroboration in the form of
therapist notes she's actually gotten
more and more yesterday we found out
that that she had remembered that she
had told people but she wasn't sure
exactly who and so
then her team came up with documents
essentially saying these friends have
specific memories of her telling them
about this and so her story appears to
be growing growing stronger on the or
gathering stronger supported more
evidence on the other hand there's been
a rush of very confusing hard to
understand allegations kind of on both
sides in the last 24 hours
more women potentially it's saying that
they had really difficult experiences
with Kavanagh but also men saying that
they think they might have been the ones
it is very hard journalists haven't
really had time to do their jobs in
terms of carefully looking at these
allegations interviewing everybody
finding support I mean when we did the
Harvey Weinstein story it tooks it took
us months and months to review
everything and saying here are the facts
that we can really support here's the
evidence here's the proof so there is a
bit of chaos going into today's hearing
it is chaotic and and also very it's
very eerily deja vu - Anita Hill except
back then Anita Hill was not believed
even after her testimony the polls show
she was not believed do you think it's
different for Christine lousy for today
absolutely if you look back at the
headlines and the historical records
from the Clarence Thomas hearing one of
the striking things is that the country
was on his side and I don't think we can
say the same is true today
she's been greeted with enormous
sympathy the activism and the show of
support you're gonna see for many women
and men today he does but I think the
sort of presumption of innocence for the
man who's being accused the idea that
you know a meddlesome woman is is
interfering with his life and trying to
bring him down is greatly changed from
the Anita Hill era ok thanks so much
Gerry